♪ (music) ♪
If you need to give
a deeply nested widget access to data
stored near the top of the widget tree,
InheritedWidget is a great way to do it.
You just make your own subclass,
add a field or two for your data,
and override the updateShouldNotify method,
which determines whether
dependent widgets should get rebuilt
if the InheritedWidget is replaced.
Descendants can inherit from your widget
in their build methods,
and off they go.
If the InheritedWidget gets replaced,
updateShouldNotify kicks in
and decides whether to rebuild
the descendants all at once.
But what if those widgets
are expensive to rebuild?
Wouldn't it be nice if they could depend
on a particular piece
of that ancestor's data,
instead of the whole widget?
For that, there's InheritedModel.
It works just like InheritedWidget,
but when descendants inherit from it,
they provide an aspect parameter
to indicate which fields they care about,
and InheritedModel has
an additional method you can override
called updateShouldNotifyDependent.
It runs once for each descendant
to determine whether that widget
needs to be rebuilt.
So your inherited model
can check the aspect for that widget
and return true to rebuild
or false to keep things as is.
So whether your widget
needs to store two colors
or a dozen live network connections,
InheritedModel can help you rebuild
its descendants only when necessary.
For more info on InheritedModel
and all the other Flutter widgets,
head to flutter.io
♪ (music) ♪